[موسيقى]
الصورة الرمزية الملوك ساشا منطقية
توريس المتحدة
فيلين الرب واللوم نعم يلعب
اللحم المفروم الآن مرات طبيبك يستعجل
لك
انها اختصار ملفات dolores طويلة دون وقت لاحق
أعطانا فائدة 8 أستانا سومي
اختبار الجهاز 1 باهت
رينجو تتخلى عن الاتصال والأرقام إنها الأرمن
خاصة بك الحفظ
n و n سلسلة خاصة الحبل الأسرة هي
فقط رينجا أو تحركات الطيران التي سيعطيها المجلس
ضع الميداليات و أمريكا و على العظم
الرونية dohlyaki سخيف jellied لا يزال قيد التشغيل
فايروس
ليس لدي دم روسي لكنك بسيط
السؤال هو كيف أشعر للحظة
أشك في أن أجيب لكم أنني سأثبت الروسية
مهمتك ليست تنانينك تتحدث
أنت تشبه الروسي لدينا
الفذ يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون لديه حساسية للحكم عليها
لي هو بيسون سوريا هنا أنا بيوفاك
والد مرة
نظرت من النافذة إلى امرأة بيضاء
وفي ذلك الوقت كان من المستحيل النظر إليه
المرأة البيضاء وكان يخشى أن يحصل
الإعدام خارج نطاق القانون
المستأجرين الياقوت دعونا جاديدس مع هذا
سيدة فيبي متأكد نيل المخللات المرجانية على
لنا من
الكاتب هنا هو شروط القضية لتجد هناك
زيارة بلغاريا فيلم جديد المسروقات التي تدرس
هل تعرف نوع السيارة التي لديك؟
سيارة جميلة تكتك الدفعة
جاءه
يجري العمل على أوهام الجسم
gooey أضرم النار مرات الكوبيين لك
ملحوظة: كلا الأسلوبين دبي جلس وهو
مذكرة مي نامي أيهم
و
[موسيقى]
كان اسم جدتي بيرتا ألكساندروفنا
بيليك الجد أوليفر الجد الذهبي
كان ابنًا أمريكيًا من أصل أفريقي لعبد لهؤلاء
في بعض الأحيان قرار جدتي الخروج
تتزوج أو تربط مصيرك بجدك
فتاة بيضاء مع الأمريكيين السود
لم يسمع به وأجدادي
ظنوا أنه ليس لديهم مستقبل
مثل زوجين مشتركين في مزيج أمريكا
لاصق الجص وما لا
أوامر وما هي الحقيقة
مكثفة للغاية أتشكل من قبل
ليلة القادمة الهزلية
الجنس ميريوالد
موقع عالم تسمية البتولا لماذا بلدي
سيكون الأجداد حول الاتحاد السوفياتي
حسنًا ، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لأنهم كانوا كذلك
مفتونين بأفكار الشيوعية
والاشتراكية ثانيًا بالطبع الفكر
حول حقيقة أنهم سيعيشون في بلد حيث
لا عنصرية كانت جذابة للغاية
البطاقات.
[موسيقى]
غطست أساطير الروك هذه الوسادة مايكل
يسقط فرصة صغيرة أوم والبريد المزعج
وسميث باتشينين الخاص بك
وهو أنفك وديدانك
أبطال وباس بندر alvezin
ش انها تدفع ن الخاص بك
وألقى في الليل في
العنصر
ولكن فقط من تذكر نعم أنت فقط
كان المصنع العطر الأول وبشكل عام
أبل ستطلق الحرب في سوريا
وظائف الربيع اختبار العلم و
جلس نظام المرأة بوريسبول جدير
له وهكذا ننتهي
الذي للطبقة اللاصقة ليس تحليلك
uning تحليل خاص به ما لا ddr
. داخل يريدون منهم
رأيي أنها سمعت وهو
[موسيقى]
7 جديرة بميكانيكي سيارات
هنا تذكره خدمة الفيلق فقط
[موسيقى]
نوكيا
ماذا تقول جيدا أنت لست جاسوس سوبر ستار
ساكاس لفيكتوريا
حتى شراء يعطي الارتفاع الإجمالي عن طريق الحجر
له
[موسيقى]
سكب الباندا له واسمها أ
الطفل هو فشلنا
يصبح كبير حتى تصبح شيزا
طفل طيب بالطبع الخادم ذ
الاسبان
صلصة الباربكيو اختيار kirov من السلطة الموالية
جوهر حول الشواذ
أولغا لن يلقي هناك
سيكون الإرهاب لتحمل xml alabai
ومحبتي وتوقفوا في يونيو
أوتينا
ليس اطول
[موسيقى]
وانا له باري ليفينسون
41 بلدًا واسعًا موطني الأصلي
حتى winton بحكم الواقع بالنسبة لي في
يونيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تأكد من القول أن هذا هو جثم
المسيح هو رأس القرف
هذا يعني أن بلادنا ليست كذلك
تسكين
جعلتني واشنطن جسديا كبيرة
لقد انتهيت من هذا الفيلم الذي حصلت عليه
عرفتني الشهرة الهائلة للوديان
لأنه أحب هذا الفيلم عندما كنا
مشى أمام المنصة
ثم ستالين ، لكنني سأخرج
نفسي ثم الأبيض كنت سأكون قليلا
داكن جدا
آخر قارب وادي الشمس مقهى دارلينج
إعادة تسمية أمريكا الأفرو التمتع الهدوء ليلي
أو في المقهى المفضل لديك
سحابة رقاقات بنفسجية حديثة
مرحبا نعم في أي مكان أقنعة لزيارة التدبير
turisas الحياة أو مع أشجار عيد الميلاد zlife الحق
عجلات سارة باريس هو الهدف الذي تبحث عنه
الشحوم ستالين الحدس
تضغط على نفسك وأنواع البومة البومة
[موسيقى]
أنا
افتتح
وردة ضائعة من اسم وبوابة هانسا و
ذهب مع والده والدي
روبرت هاري رايز جونسون أتى إلى هنا
اثنان و ثلاثون
كيف كان يصور النهر مع المهاجرين
الكثير من الأفلام على موسفيلم
استوديوهات غوركي
yalta film studio from كنتاكي سيدي
سأسميك ما نوع العمل الذي كانت عليه
مضيفون يقتلون برو شيلبي وفي أمريكا
يمكنه التمثيل ويكون ممثلاً في ذلك الوقت
في ذلك الوقت لا شك أنه
ولدت المدينة على حد سواء
هذه هي حالة أرضية ألاباما لذا لم تكن شديدة
عنصري
[موسيقى]
ناتاليا نحن نصلب باهتمام روبرت روز
سارا الأخرى عادة ما تفعل tuatara الابتعاد أنا
أيضا
فيدوروف وعقلك هما الأسماء المستعارة الوحيدة
جيمس والأمل شارع ولايات ل
تذاكر jessa 10 مايو لأوكو ديفي داشي
لا تجد سام لهم من المصارعة
قطع من رمز الديكور 1 سبارتاك
موسكو
عندما كانوا بطريقة ما دنيبروبيتروفسك
أطلق بيسكوف سراح قاعدته وعندما كان
خرج
اندلع تصفيق مدو
كان أول فتى أسود
كرة القدم السوفيتية
المحتفلين في المحيط هذا ليس للمسلمين
تسليم كلية الفنون التطبيقية
لقد فهم الجميع ما سيقوله في منطقتي
كلمات ليست مسيئة عن لون بشرتي جدا
أستاخوف خطير أثناء دخول أمريكا مجانًا
عودة سيئة السمعة أو عالم الجنيات الصامت
إلى الأجداد ، لم أفهم حقًا ما كان عليه
لذلك سأقوم على الفور بمهام محسوسة
عجلة القيادة لها على يوتيوب
أوليا في أمريكا جوليا و 2 7 وجديد
و lapushkin والمنزل والقط العالِم يرتدي كل شيء
يمشي حول السلسلة ولكن حول تفريغها
يقول عواء من حكاية السم
كثيرا ما يسألني ما إذا كنت قد اختبرت
الاتحاد السوفياتي العنصري
نعم بالطبع فعلت
بدون لوبان ، أيضًا ، سأستعين بمهندس
ضع كل من وسائل الإعلام ايلينا هانجا
في بعض الأحيان هناك تلفزيون العملة لا
هايتي سام لا يحتاجون إليه فقط
إعطاء والتفصيل من الحانات و mophie بعيدًا
halberds نفس الفيروس الذي دفعوه
إلى جانب مساء الخير أيها السادة الكرام
شكرًا لك على حضور عرضنا 1
في روسيا ضغط على الحب والجنس
سميت بأسماء بسبب لون بشرتي
تسمى الأسماء لأنها لا تشبه
الآخرين عندما كنت صغيرا
كثيرًا ما طُلب مني الإبلاغ باللون الأسود
قلت الأطفال
لكن حقيقة أن والدي وراء إفريقيا هي مزحة
انتظر لكنك ولدت في موسكو
الجو بارد هنا في الشتاء حتى يجب أن يكون أبيض
حتى الآن أصبحنا مثل
فريد غير عادي لم يكن هناك أحد
ماعدا السود
كان له وله أيضًا شتاين زولا
قادمًا أو مسافرًا لتسليمهم والملح
وأنا لست منك مثل هذا الفيلم النهري
أوزبكستان فقط نصيحة علاجية
عبارات دلما تشحن هناك ما عندهم
تأخذ Orbea thelma من حساب دورها
كان لديه مفهوم للمؤسس
أصعب جزء كان طفولتنا
اتصل بالزنجي باستمرار
أنا حقًا لم أحب إيثان ماذا أفعل
لكن عندما انتقلنا إلى موسكو خمسون
السنة الرابعة والخمسون هناك بالطبع بالفعل
كان أسهل بكثير لأنه كان هناك
الجيش ليس أوزبكيا من جنسيات مختلفة
الأطفال ولكن عليك أن ترى الفرق بين
العنصرية في أمريكا والاتحاد الروسي
إذا كانت في أمريكا دولة
العنصرية التي كانت جزءًا
نظام الدولة ثم في الاتحاد السوفيتي
الاتحاد سيكون عنصري لكم وليس جدي
أوليفر الذهبي ليس أمي تكبر
طشقند ، لم يصادفوا أي شيء
من مظاهر العنصرية ، كان لديهم
مشاكل لأنها كانت
الأمريكيون أولا لا الجد لا
لم يتم قبول الجدة في يخدع الحزب
الاتحاد السوفياتي وأساء
[موسيقى]
الصين الشقراء كنت تطير خارجا غاب عنك هنا
كوخ TXT
العالمية
اي فون نجمي الفالس
[موسيقى]
ألينا في أمي
لعبت من تقسيم البيض Shoigu
دفعت ساندرا الأدوية للولادة
[موسيقى]
الذين كان لدي نموذجي في روسيا
اللقب مظهر غير نمطي
ولكن كانت هناك بعض الميزات التي لا أستطيع
قل هذا مثل هذا بطريقة أو بأخرى
أثرت على حياتي كنت هناك كما لو
لم يؤخذ في مكان ما بسبب هذا أو هناك
شيء لم يسمح لي بفعله أو كيف حالك
لقد تم إزالتي بطريقة ما من هذا
مقصلة لدباغة تلمارين
المشي عالياً لم يصل إلى أمريكا الأفرو
مسطرة آمنة جديدة ذ يتم تمرير هذه الحقول
مشى جورج الرقص منتصف الليل كانت هذه
إنه نوع من ربط انطباعي
كان هذا هو الانطباع الأول
شخص وصل من الاتحاد السوفيتي
هناك كل شيء في حد ذاته
الطرق المنظمة بشكل معقول جيدة
حيث يتوفر سعر الطعام في المحلات
هل يمكنك الذهاب إلى هناك ليلا لشراء بيرة؟
بالنسبة لي كان هناك في الاتحاد السوفياتي
ما هو غير واقعي
نعم كان عدد السود
فجأة رأيت أن الكثير من السود
رأيت أشخاصًا يقودون سيارات باهظة الثمن
حول حقيقة أن الشباب الأسود إذا جاز التعبير
يتصرف جامحًا تمامًا
مثلما لدينا هنا السبانخ
شعرت بنوع من العودة إلى
وطن تاريخي
نعم ، كان شيء من هذا القبيل عابرًا
كان نوعًا من الخوف متعلقًا بما هو هذا هنا
الأرض التي ينتمي إليها جدي ، ولكنك
بقيت لأعيش ولم أبق هناك
لعدد من الأسباب ، لم أفهم ذلك في الواقع
ماذا وهناك مثل هذا سأفعله على الفور
ولماذا أذهب إلى العمل الآن
في ماكدونالدز أعلى بقليل
شكلت
تحدثت أنهم ما زالوا نشأت في روسيا
مع الناس الذين يتحدثون الروسية
الذين يقرؤون الكتب الروسية هناك
دوستويفسكي في أمريكا لديهم لهجات
بطريقة أو بأخرى تحولت إلى نوع من ما أنا عليه الآن
لا أعرف أي نوع من الأعمال العملية لديهم
مثيرة للاهتمام بطريقتهم الخاصة ولكن ليس الآخرين
شعرت أنني ما زلت عزيزة
التواصل الذي لدي في روسيا
هنا يعود فرع العتاد الصينية
كانت غرف هذا المحرك من الزارعين
أمريكا ، أنا مثل هذا القطب أو Alle Gulya
طعام النمل الأبيض هنا وأمي المخلل
الحقيقة هي أنها مريحة للغاية و
يقول الناس هنا آه حياة مريحة للغاية
بالطبع أنا في روسيا من قلبي
الثقافة الأمريكية الأفريقية لست جدا
أنا أفهم الثقافة الروسية كثيرا
أغلق السنوات الماضية هنا أسمع وأرى
بالطبع على شاشة التلفزيون أن هذه كلها
قتل الأمريكيين الأفارقة الأمريكيين الأفارقة
التي ولدت من البيانات بالفعل في نفس الوقت
الأسرة الفقيرة بالطبع الخروج في نفس الوقت
من مستوى إلى آخر
يكاد يكون من المستحيل لأن
حصلنا على التعليم هنا
التعليم في الاتحاد السوفياتي ولنا
تعطى الفرصة مجانا
في البداية درست في موسكو
معهد الإدارة ثم تخرجت
الزنجبيل في الأكاديمية الروسية الشعبية
المزارع
تعليمتين أعلى ولكن في الواقع تصل إلى
انت في المكتب الان
الشركة التي أنا فيها
المساهمين وفي نفس الوقت أنا
رئيس نفس الشركة
الأعمال المتوسطة ، أي أنها بمليار
حجم مبيعات الشركة مليار روبل تصل إلى
مليار روبل ، أي نوع من السيارات لديك
لاحظت كم هي جميلة السيارة التي عليها
لقد وصلت جاكوار في بلدي موسكو الآن
حصلت ابنة أخت فرانسين تتساءل ماذا
ولدت في موسكو
انتقلت مع والدتها إلى الولايات المتحدة
عاش هناك تقريبا كل منها
الحياة الواعية
والآن قررت العودة إلى
روسيا
روميكا البيضاء ستلتقط ظلام شارعك
ليف تنتهي ولكن هل هو كثير بالنسبة لهم
موسم الطرق تم اكتشافه بواسطة trainz لأنك
نحن نصدقك من سمارة إلى كب كيك
أوه أوه أوه أوه أوه أوه أوه أوه
كان لديه إشارة فقط
[موسيقى]
المعبود في موسكو لأي
س مثل هذا وتعليم اللغة الإنجليزية ماتيشا
آسوس ولك
أساء في عالمك
ألقى كأس من الملك nmc
أسرع المطلعين السود الشرير ميا
جائزة من ضريبة القيمة المضافة
[موسيقى]
كمية الأمونيا من فيلاتك اللغوية
يقف نرسم محاضر من المكتب
زهور اللورد الاتصال
مع ثعبان الشاي جي يون سو
العباكان لك وكان هناك ملاك
[موسيقى]
لم أجد هذه القطعة مني في المنزل
هذا هو بيتي بالنسبة لي
شاي مثلج يصل إلى 1 صب
إنها مهمتك أن تمارس عصر التنين
أبيض أنت روسي
لا تستطيع الرؤية
يعتقد جدي أن التنس رمز
ما هو رمز الازدهار للنجاح الأبيض
يفعل الناس لأثريائهم
الأطفال وكان يريد إنجاب طفل
نفس الأشياء هنا هي نفسها تمامًا
ماذا فعل الرجل الابيض الغني وكيف حالك
فكر فيما فعلت عندما ولدت
ابنة ل ios 5 أو 6 سنوات أعطت سيارة
نيسان وأصلع وصرخت لم أفعل
اريد لا اريد قلت لو جدي
قال أنك في طريقك
همهم
[موسيقى]
سؤال صعب جدا كيف
مصير أجدادي إذا
لم يبقوا في الاتحاد السوفيتي
سيبقى في نيويورك لكنني أعرف ذلك بالتأكيد
ماذا لو الآن الجد والجدة
انظروا من فوق فهم فخورون جدا
بالنظر إلى التيار من أمي ، عاشت الحياة بعد ذلك
كيف فعلت مصيري وفكرت فيه
كيف يعيش لي الآن؟
[موسيقى]
نحن أطفال ملونون
ولد في دولة سوفيتية
ويسعدني أنكم من الآن فصاعداً أنتم وطننا
ذهب
نحن نحب وطننا ونقدره لا حيث لسنا
سوف تكون أكثر حرية
وإذا سئلنا سنقول
أخرى ولكن
اصحاب
لذلك دع العالم كله يعرف
الحرية هنا أثناء المد ونحن أطفال
الناس الملونين
يأخذ
[موسيقى]
الجانب السوفيتي